yeah this was a nice introduction and
welcome to the session of all its energy
and particular transfer learning the NFP
right now it's really exciting time to
work in energy but it's also developing
and such an incredible pace that
sometimes be difficult to keep on track
with the latest developments so I hope
this session today will help you to get
a bit up to speed with transfer learning
NLP latest language models that actually
use for that and also show you that how
to use those models in your daily work
in my daily work
I actually deal with both sides of NLP
on the one hand side research and on the
other hand side the industry in research
station up here
I would say it's a lot about transfer
learning or conferences are basically
flooded with papers around their topic
we see new language models basically on
a weekly basis and also there's new
state of the art performances published
for downstream tasks like question
answering or semester language but on
the other hand with the industry and
they have quite some different
requirements when it comes to appeal
it's just deploying at scale different
data different domain language so
there's quite a gap between those two
sides and my daily job I basically try
to bridge that gap from industry to
research and that's why two years ago we
found that you set small Silicon Valley
where we try to do exactly that and we
do that basically three different
approaches on the one hand side we have
open-source software models that we
publish three further but use three for
developers and then we top of that some
enterprise features
eat when you want to cry at scale and we
do some custom development and plans
often not sure what's happening with the
screen but we'll be back soon
[Music]
all right so that's my day job for today
I would like to UM go this through
transfer and explain the major concept
behind it then look at one core
component of transfer learning the
language model itself and different
variants of it then going over to some
education class the lifestyle of these
days question answering because there we
really see the biggest improvements and
then finally the Sun window not so what
is transfer learning in here basically
here is pretty simple and I think once
yesterday they were already quite some
talks about it it's basically you take
one huge data set train what about that
and this model requires some kind of
knowledge that's saved and this
knowledge you want then transfer to a
different task to a different model and
by doing that you actually need that way
more to a smaller data set for your
second task so the model not only learns
from the second data set but also has
some kicks are basically with some prior
knowledge that's the basic idea
advance from that is mostly to meet less
labels for your task and you get a
better performance this is I would say
pretty much the sweet dream of every
machining engineer better performance
with less labels and also labels lot of
applications in the industry to other
matters that are not mentioned that
often but for me quite important yes
also has a big implication on your
development cycle engine development
style we experience that really
accelerates your development work this
is just pasta and on the other engines
gets more standardized and lets you
reuse a lot of components across
projects across different tasks in your
company which which helps a lot to leave
these silos transferred is not new at
all
it has been around in computer vision
for years so I guess some of you come
from this year and know that there was
image net I think published in 2011-12
that huge collection of images imitated
with objects and people use pairs to
train the model this model learned some
basic knowledge quotation marks is
geometry some textures and this model
was then able to transfer it to top
stream tasks to other applications for
example is a fight and screws in in the
industry quite boring tasks but it's
many tasks in the industry so people
also tried that we can achieve and it
didn't really work for a long time and
what people try to do is also putting in
a large text corpora for example the GP
a-- and learning some kind of model and
he smothers usually also learn some kind
of music knowledge some general
understanding of language it's been hard
to visualize this knowledge it's usually
some kind of word embedding some
pseudonyms that get similar
Thank You person space something was to
text in this motion can be transferred
to another class for example in the
industry classifying legal contracts and
people tried that but never really was
not working a similar scale like
well the good news now is it's working
fine and I think this is only happened
within the last year and this is
exciting and yeah pretty much one year
ago and November December last year
there was a model published but which
basically really kicked off stream of
development which scheme of research
technique this accelerating this
transfer of extreme energy and since
this like only this last year it had a
big impact on a lot of different areas
of energy
first of all research right now he's
kind of models are dominating all or
mostly all leaderboards one that I'm
particularly excited about
SWAT stapler question-answering data set
for the task of question answering and
we see here is basically the timeline
and performance at what's work and what
received one year ago there was a bump
and this bump was due to the sky Bert a
model touched by Google which is common
that right now they used to the most
prominent examples transferred but it's
not only that some only used in in
research but it's also a lot of
implications in industry a few weeks ago
the announced that they are not using it
for 10 percent of their search queries
in the US and repeated off search state
that was the biggest positive change
within the last five years and this cost
a lot of headlines I was very surprised
and we get read some newspapers and I
saw an AP bird on the front page of some
generic German newspaper and it really
showed me okay this is not making the
step into the industry
it's not only researchers not only stuff
that you read in newsletters from
Scottsdale una but it's really getting
out there and actually years ago we're
not there also rolling it off for
seventy other languages so it's not only
in the US anymore for some a couple
years that we know but at what scale you
have to imagine millions of search
queries and if you months ago ever said
yeah you know okay there's the Spencer
learning but yeah this transform others
they're so huge impractical for my use
case Google is not sure that you can do
it if you want and if it's if there's
business value for you and they all did
that within one year last not only is
this also has big implications on style
of work for us as machine in the
engineers of data scientists I think the
last years they pretty much felt like
crazy right building these soap boxes
you try to you look for the best model
for your particular task engineer here
future engineer here additional layers
and in the end you had something that
worked it was super fun you basically
won this race maybe that wasn't really
sustainable and I think this is not
changing we go from these individual
models individual silos for each
particular task to a more standardized
way of trying energy of training models
and I think this is it's pretty much
subscribe by building on the shoulders
of giants so you take these big three
trend models and apply it or fine-tune
it for your particular domain and this
changes the whole style of working also
more an operational level we focus on
our team experience that we basically
completely Chester's development from
local machines to remote interpreters in
the cloud having GPUs so not only using
GPUs anymore for only for training but
also in development using that as
because these smalls are super big and
just typical to what they were cpu and
experience so how exactly is transfer
living now performed in anarchy what
different phases do we have there
they are different styles of
transferring but most of the time right
now when should we talk about it it's
sequential transferring and sequential
transfer learning has three phases the
first one basically taking over each
text corpus and training a language
model from scratch on the surface the
same face is an optional face if you
work in some domain where the language
is a bit more specific for example in
biomedicine or in some technical
engineering environment then you might
want to adapt this language model to a
certain to main course
so basically new training for a
particular domain in the third and last
phase in transfer learning is in
actually applying your model to a
downstream task so basically the task
that you're really interested in this
might give a named entity recognition
document classification question
answering search whatever
so these language models are believed a
quad component in this transfer learning
paradigm so let's have a look into what
the edge they are the idea of limas ones
are pretty straightforward you have a
sentence and you mask out a certain word
and if you read not as human there's a
sentence you already think automatically
what is the word missing here in the
middle the Fox over the street and you
already came up with ideas about this
and it might be the Fox runs over the
speed walks over the street jumps
whatsoever and as faster seems very
simple but it's actually super powerful
in the machine learning world and the
reason for that is that you need
to understand context to master this
task and understanding context means
that you need on the one inside subtext
but also semantics you need to
understand what this sentences are from
a Content perspective but also the
subtext is important in this example for
example tea the runs with an S in
English you need to write communication
right for work the last reason why it's
powerful and by its family used it's
very cheap to train or to face training
data you don't need any humans to
imitate your examples you can just fill
in any text and automatically create
examples by blinking upwards so that's
super powerful I think in every if most
every model out there is probably used
so that's a quick look these names
models can on the one side be used for
generating language on the other hand
site for understanding language right
now let's try to generate some text to
that there's a website called Fox
transformers which is basically
deploying one of the most prominent
models out there gp2 it's running not
the biggest moments not the most
powerful one but rather small version of
it but it's I think enough for for
playground with it is rather fast
so yeah that's maybe try to fit in some
text let's maybe say
agents against so from aliens from the
race transport and let's see what they
were smaller doesn't that cut its
opponent that much of Italy to be make
is family from all or and is found by
album travelers looking for country that
can hands and spread their whatever each
one and so on and so on
and so what that family here is
basically that model one word after the
other samples and predicts what comes
next
and it was didn't think about this is
now that these recent models really
managed to achieve the context over
quite some some long sequence so it
means that you will can create stories
that makes some kind of sense often they
also worship to the others but at least
they are chromatically correct and they
pick up the initial idea also after two
sentences anybody else with a sense that
she wants to try okay then yeah maybe
won't play around with at home it's fun
they're different variants
so these neighbors ones can get one
inside just be used for generating
languages we saw but more often they
actually used for understanding language
for these downstream tasks like entity
recognition and one very prominent model
out there I already mentioned it but
released one year ago like who works and
it was basically trained on a pre-trade
with two objectives to tastin the
beginning the one is the mass language
model so just what we saw and the second
one is next sentence prediction we will
see that in a minute
it was trained on about 30 gigabyte of
data using Wikipedia and some public
available books so let's now go through
each of these three phases pre-training
main application
downstream and see what what actually is
done in these phases and I also tried to
do some tips recommendations that we
found useful working with these kind of
models in the last year so when you try
to scratch you basically fit in there
are sentences so one here and one here
you must add some words and you filled
in to the model architecture what about
that we have two different prediction
has one focus to an acceptance
prediction and the other one on language
modeling and this is an acceptance
prediction basically tells you only to
predict if these sentences come one
after the other in the original document
or not in this case probably not they
all belong together and language model
fills in the blanks as we just saw if
you want to really train such a model
from scratch what what when is it useful
I would say in from the 80% of the cases
it's not useful it's only useful if your
child language is very different from
the ones that are already published so
this the model for English there's a
really trained model for German and I
think no there's no model for Polish so
this would make sense
it also in some domains where you main
language is super different then might
make sense of transgression it only
makes sense if you have roughly about
thinking about of textes I will say in
in your in your application it really
means having small performance gains and
from the modeling side translates to big
business value so if you start off here
just a smaller case might not make sense
but if you are in corporate with many
applications of that also 1% performance
a lot if you would look at the mentor
training smaller base model first so
they always variants a smaller model and
then you once you which ones tend to
converge more strangely or we saw
difficult parents there the smaller ones
are nicer and better to start with and
then this these ones are usually quite
robust in terms of high parameters one
single premier that is not robust is the
learning rate so keep that really in
mind this has a lot of money together so
usually it's better to start with some
smaller learning rate and then pump it
up so I have any learning rate schedules
for example this is and then one trick
that is actually have to define a
maximum sequence length that you fit in
into the smaller and the longer strands
like this the more computation you need
in this model it's actually credit we're
quite wretched so what helps is that
during the training from scratch do 90
percent of the training actually quite
small sequence length quite fast and
then only last 10 percent you do want
the really low sequence name this is
enough for the motor to also deal with
the longer ones and it has to go from
we saw pre-training down to a few days
so now we have a pre trained language
model and the second phase is then if
you are working certain domain adapted
to this particular language that you
have and when you do there is basically
continuing the same style of training
that we saw before the with it changes
what you feed you feed now in not PA
text anymore but for example some some
either text from contracts and this is
useful if you are working in a domain
with some particular parents particular
variations in my experience that
actually is the case in most companies
maybe news is a bit different but for
all others I've seen there's usually
some specifics in the domain and this
space is already helpful if you have
roughly about 5 gigabyte of text data
I also case with 12 megabytes with some
seduced so it's worth trying
most cases it also helps but it's useful
if for your final downstream training
you only have very few training centers
so in contrast let's say with downstream
tasks document classification and you
have 10 million annotated examples then
this space doesn't make sense for you
because in the stance you toss the model
they already have enough time to adapt
to this domain and they're all specifics
then you don't need this I can be is
that if you do this again flow rate
start with a stretch comes up as someone
what should also do here is modified
vocabulary so for example the standards
berg has around 30,000 tokens in the
open and there are 3,000 unused Toki's
basically placeholders and they just
exchanged those placeholders with your
own
terms that come up in your language
many companies that's product names
every ations
and so on but also help them make it for
later be conductive is experimenting
with additional tasks so we have here
this next sentence task and language
modeling but in some domains you also
have access to additional meta
information so for example what kind of
contract this sentence comes from and
you can do some classification as a
third task this also that helps to learn
more about the domain that way so if
you've done all that we we are now in
the final phase downstream so you will
really see them the fruits of your work
where you can help them and they are one
example exemplary downstream task might
be classification so now you listen take
this but motor from the previous steps
but you remove the relations heads that
we saw before and put instead of
classification head this is just if you
want to send the layers new network and
it's very cheap to add this and then you
can actually predict what topic the
sentence first is about these relation
heads really something like a swiss
knife you can exchange easily now what
tasks you want to apply this module you
can put here and entity recognition
question answering you name it basically
all energy tasks so this was not all
about birds and I think it's still one
of the most popular central models that
we have out there but as I said
in the Spiritist developing at an
incredible pace and there are new
language models out there every week and
some I think it's not important to
understand all of them but it's quite
helpful to see what kind of trends are
there what are the next language models
about so let me put a few of them up
here there was a while ago a model
called Stanford and but the office tip
there is actually changing the objective
of the language model from only masking
single tokens to actually masking full
stem so multiple talks that was quite
interesting yeah they had something then
there was this Roberta published by
Facebook and what they basically did is
they took one Dana train for a longer
time using a larger exercise and they
also got rid of the next census
prediction and also that one who stopped
performance quite quite a lot so I think
this also some general pattern for these
kind of models more data videos and then
they recently Google publish Edward
which is dominating benchmarks about the
awards and they had also some
interesting ideas how to go on with
these architectures but we can change
and what they do is basically they make
this model more efficient by sharing
ways across different layers different
transform laws and they vectorized in
varies so basically beginning this say
with vocabulary of 30,000 tokens you
would have metrics of 30,000 times you
are very dimensionality and with this
declaration
basic reduce that to a few matrix
multiplications that are way cheaper in
terms of memory and they also vary the
next sentence prediction of it so we
already see the solution
situation of birth is probably not the
future there's a lot of experiments to
change that the last direction monocytes
so these models are quite huge they need
is trained on GPUs and now there are a
lot of attempts to bring them down to
change actually run them on even mobile
devices and to models there Cubert is
papered they believe so small that you
can run them on TV so you're not all
right and they still have around 90% of
performance of the original models
that's not more there's way more I would
know go to these details I will share
the slides of course and maybe if you
look for a language model in particular
tasks
this might be a good starting point one
topic that's actually quite a lot is
that most of these language models are
focusing on English language and so what
about non-english languages what about
polish what about German there are these
mighty lingual models but they are
always working well for for your
particular language so yes you said try
to promote also these language models in
other languages
we trained an open source the German one
we're currently training Joan Abbott and
we have some collaboration with Google
so if you were interested in for example
finding a modern your language polish
maybe please approach me
we have spotted with knowledge code and
also with GQ section in the book so now
we know more about these language models
what can you do with them let's focus on
one task one application called question
answering
and I think it's best explained again
with the devil what is question
answering
what's at this table again is public if
you want to play around with it just go
to this website and it's all open source
so we can even deploy this by easily
with a block card own infrastructure
replace which all models in here
whatever you like so in question
answering the basically have to push it
in one passage or one document and then
we can ask questions that might be
answered from this document and we have
some examples up here but I really
prefer I don't trust these through these
examples so let's let's try something
different
we can cross Center so let's take the
wiki article from ecological tankers you
can just paste this mutual two
passengers here and now we can start
asking questions so what do you want to
know about cocaine because maybe what
did
and the one of the Mississippi scheduled
text and tries to identify spam that
answers this question and we find that
Copernicus formulated a model of the
universe that placed the Sun rather than
earth at the center of the universe
quite I would say so let's try something
else
when did so also here the more basic he
identifies this date as the date of
death but the work is not meant but not
mentioned at all and this is something
important that has changed now similar
question-answer systems work before but
they all always rely on Reese keyword
matching or very similar words giving
this context and this is no different
with you some recent later words you can
also ask of course where did you live
in royal pressure and what is that and
what is
basically if that had been part of the
kingdom of Poland since 1466 so you see
this you can they use this to its basic
diversity into text and that's how this
is right now only on a small passage
what we do now in projects is actually
doing that on large scale having
thousands of documents which other space
in the background and having them
basically tool dashboard for people
where they can type in and analyze
documents and other centers or local
source so someone I said once question
answering
basically question message and you
extract and answer all of that that's
what we also call extractive question
answering there's also other variants
that are quite interesting right now we
have for example one we're buying the
answers yes or no or you want to
generate a question that generate
answers so you don't need to have the
answers written anymore in the text
itself there's also multiple QA which is
sometimes the answers in different
locations of the document and you need
to aggregate those piece of information
to actually come up with the final
answer and this is all super hot right
now or conferences are basically
focusing on that and it's there's a lot
of applications so let's look at this
another word I don't have time to
divulge details unfortunately but I
think as engineers you're interested
also and what are they not only the UI
verifications um as you see before we
have come on let's for example take
third language model and now we've
hidden text but what we feed them out
here's the question some separation and
then the extra message both at one time
and what we get them out of this
language model is basically a
contextualized or contextualized talking
basics of
each talking down here we got a back
door we feed these factors to our
prediction hat for question answering
and this question answering help them
predicts which one is the star token of
the answer and the end roll and this
gives us an Indian T final stand that we
convert that to to speak space and maybe
what ascending on this question
answering had as I said there's vectors
for token going into this prediction
head and then it's only a very channel
feed-forward Network
it's basically has one input layer and
output layer neurons and these two
neurons
give us launchers probability for the
this token right now is the start of the
answer or the end of the answer and we
basically run this feed forward Network
for for each of the token embeddings who
gets the start and end logic for of the
stroke and we applied for the
wholesomeness and this gives us them in
the end
overview of this world message of the
sequence and we pick the form with the
highest start budget and the one with
the highest intelligence combine them to
consonant there's one extra told those
specialty I will say many cases it's
helpful if the model has also the option
to say there is no answer in the text
and this is why I keep it as the extra
form in the beginning so the model can
also predict there's no information in
this text I cannot answer it and there's
pretty much what happens on the modern
side so also there if you look into it
it's really really simple and there's
thousands of things that you can prove
and that's what
makes me really excited about this view
because there's tons of opportunities so
how can you not implement that lucky yes
very well-established and a lot of
frameworks out there I only will
highlight a few of them right now
there's more one my thing that's very
popular these days is transform us from
one phase and what they do is basically
providing the very last connection of of
models so it can be quite sure if
there's an implication it will be
implemented in this library they're both
white watch and tensorflow and they have
quite some large research community so
if you want to focus on the one thing
sighs just take this clay model out
there this is a definite recommendation
um we also started using huggy face
basically what ya go and contributor to
this open source community develop some
features after why we saw in for really
providing transfer in the industry we
needed a few more features and that's
why we decided to create an own
framework called farm also sauce and
there or what was really taking these
transformer models from happy face but
providing some additional utility layer
on top that is more scalable it's faster
it's easier to debug and it gives you I
think most flexibility to actually do it
very fast proof of concepts in the
industry and then also bring them into
production and then on top of that right
now we are really excited about QA
question answering that's why we're just
two weeks ago three weeks ago released
additional Franco hast egg which you
don't use to do this question answering
and scale on a single message anymore or
that thousands of documents if you
interested check it out
so it'll also I think sometimes if you
maybe Hammonds use these kind of models
yet it might be use it's intimidating
but it's actually from Co perspective
right now pretty simple and here's one
example how to train a
question-answering model it's basically
these few lines of code some data
processing before for datasets modeling
bit and then the training bit there's
also a collab notebook here called QA
question answering and there's tons of
tutorials father frameworks as well so
let's summarize key statement for say
from my site transfer learning is
working and it's that it was a look for
the projects if you went to Italy it's
right now changing a lot research
industry but also started working in
particular question-answering and see
cement into tasks like summarization
they make incredible progress and this
gives of course exciting opportunities
for for the industry safe service
websites I imagine in the future that
also no documents we don't whatever you
know for search or maybe confer queue
for answer questions and the particular
culture intends to means science finance
so what is ahead I think next steps
probably that we will see more grounds
model efficiency and stability so really
scaled humble smothers while keeping the
forms something you super excited and we
have to scale them in production they
are sort of interesting ideas for new
strategies in transfer learning in
particular I can recommend this paper g5
of Google yes yes
every NLP task to convert it into a text
to text task so if you did some texting
you get awesome text even for
classification yard and this have costs
them really like like one model to rule
them all and I think it could buy
interesting direction generative to aim
if you talked about that one and then in
the end of the road I think right now
these most of these models all of these
models actually are quite
parametric they were officially powerful
a dimension and some of you might know
the smoke from debut camera thinking
fast thinking slow where it describes
basically human thinking and he
differentiates between thinking fast and
thinking slow system 1 and system 2
thinking fastest all automated have I
mentioned behavior if you drive from the
highway of the why do you think about
what you doing anymore
well the other and system 2 thinking
fastest really reasoning thinking slowly
or Consequences putting together some
puzzle pieces and this is missing for me
right now
yes right now Europe's some discussion
panels around this topic minutes there's
more on why yes but I think it's very
sad
so if you ask me
would have asked me say five years ago
if that what we have today is AI these
questions are three models I probably
would have stayed at at least it's a
good step in this direction you asked me
today and I would say no this is not not
AI and this is what some people these
days most artists the AI effect stay AI
is whatever hasn't been done yet
and I see every time you figure out how
something works it stops the America say
okay yeah maybe the father's AI but in
the end they
from the end this is only the matrix
multiplications right so I go through
the HP Pai I think there's just an
interesting that's it from my side
thanks for we have time for questions
like one or two questions tomorrow there
yeah question here yeah thank you for
the talk about the question answering
systems I assume it requires annotated
data right the question answering
require annotated data so realistically
how much data okay thank you
all right one more back
thank you for the talk I wonder if you
have any experience with cases where the
answer for a question might appear
multiple times within the passage like
in cases where you know you take a very
long one and it might appear more than
once
same answer for that for this question
you can switch out the top k answers
document and then it's up to you what
you want to do with that in some cases
where financial analysts what do you
analyze companies and there we just
reached our nothing to top five answers
and present them also to be using games
and that's all then they can also still
decide what is correct what is also
really important not only usually to
give back the answer but also the
context so all right one more if not you
can probably find Malta over lunch or
during the coffee breaks
thank you so much Malta
[Applause]